since uh since you know finally the
pandemic's dying down more events are
opening up here in Japan as well uh I
finally got to go to my first summer Mad
City my first Summer Festival oh yeah
and uh real anime moment I assume yeah
okay here's how his own one down right
so uh I get back to Japan after
traveling from Australia and didus and
Emily hit me up being like yo we're
going to a Summer Festival and of course
huh and of course you know didus and
Emily they hear Summer Festival they see
this as an anime moment they want to go
all out right so so there's this big
group that consists of like a lot of
like Geeks plus talent and Geeks plus
staff May Lin was there as well and
everyone's like guys we're finally
having a Summer Festival episode [ __ ]
yeah okay we've got to go all [ __ ]
out so we go out to like rent yukatas
for the day like I think like Malin had
to travel like an hour or something or
wait an hour to like rent her Yukata she
you know in Mayland fashion shows up
like two hours late or some [ __ ] of
course
um I had to like travel you know travel
like half an hour to get to my closest
ucardo rental place
um I'm really excited we all like meet
up
and then we go to the Summer Festival
and it was the most like
kind of like if there was a Japanese if
if there was an in-betweener special in
Japan this would be it like we how it
went in our head was we imagined every
[ __ ] single Summer Festival episode
of anime that we've seen you know we got
like we've got like the events going on
it's like in a nice school you know it's
it's like in a nice spacious park or a
nice spacious place you've got you got
the gym the weird sexual tension the
fireworks and everything
um so we go to this place yeah and it's
in a [ __ ] car park right it's it's
it's it's impossible oh sorry sorry
so even smaller yeah it was [ __ ] tiny
right it was it was a basketball court
next to this train station right it was
like it was so so we had we we went in
and it was it was Tiny all right I was
expecting us to be able to like walk
around there'd be like different events
there'd be different shops I was waiting
to get like my [ __ ] Yaki sober get my
like shaved ice you know play that
[ __ ] minigame where you like shoot uh
shoot the thing pick up the ball pick up
the ball pick up the Goldfish and [ __ ]
like that I was waiting for that there
was none of that none of that right
there was one stand for shaved ice and
that was the longest queue of this
entire Festival right right it was even
a festival at that point or is it a
glorified
Street show
I mean it kind of was just you basically
went to like the Compton of summer
festivals basically we would me and like
all of us were standing there we spend
more time waiting for our yukatas than
it would have taken to go through
everything in this [ __ ] Festival
right this this festival and we were
just waiting in line to get our like
yakisoba and as we were waiting in this
line because it was like gated off and
we see like railway tracks and every
like 10 10 minutes of the show uh 10
minutes or so we'd have this like really
you know it wasn't even like atmospheric
right because every 10 minutes or so
you'd have the train going
I know and I was just like I got [ __ ]
dressed up for this so so why did you go
to this one another one uh because
apparently like all the good ones are
way like you have to travel like an hour
or two outside of the city yeah
yeah I saw I saw a big one not too far
from where I live that was decently way
bigger than the one you guys sent
there's a couple of big ones I've been
to as well but the problem is is that
it's either way too incredibly packed
yeah or especially during like the
covert season they like really limit the
space yeah the amount of people so like
the the they sometimes like ticket these
places now yeah so it's like you can't
just like rock up to these places
anymore yeah so this place was
incredibly small and also incredibly
packed oh yeah yeah
um there was like you're all
conglomerated
were you I was oh it was so [ __ ]
sweaty okay it's poor rentals yeah yeah
you must have given them a [ __ ] like
damp rag bro I'm pretty sure they had to
incinerate all of our you kind of I felt
so bad right and I wasn't even like the
most sweaty one there was like everyone
was like sweating through their [ __ ]
I'm I'm so glad that they give you like
space between like your pets because
holy [ __ ] if if if it was like a t-shirt
like it would our pets would be would
have been absolutely [ __ ] stained
gross and I was like there was like one
long line I was hoping this was like
actually something cool maybe it was
like a mini game or something yeah um
like I could see everyone lining up to
this one [ __ ] queue yeah and I was
like oh cool maybe no you didn't know
what you're lining up for no but you
just joined a line I I I joined the line
for like five minutes and I thought I
thought it must have been British people
when they try and have fun
online
it must be something cool it must be
something that was fun yeah that was
funny I I joined online and then I
realized wait all right I realized five
minutes in I should probably check what
this line is for so I get Sydney over
Sydney wait here in line just in case
it's something cool maybe it's like
maybe it's like one of the shooty games
maybe it's like the Goldfish game I go
up right and this is by far the longest
line where you'd have to wait in line
for about 30 minutes to get to the front
[ __ ] balloon
balloon kids can go there and buy
balloons
and kids were waiting 30 plus minutes to
go to this one stall to buy balloons and
that was the highlight of this Festival
now that's not even like traditionally
Japanese you can you can get a [ __ ]
you can do that at Disneyland as well
they sell one dollars I don't think
there's a 30 minute line it wasn't even
like a paper balloon like just like a
regular ass like plastic balloon or
a lot it's like the stall was like it's
literally so basically so once you like
you get like
you know I wanted to go to this last
year but I was sick but I think I dodged
it bullet you kind of did it actually so
we we actually we went we went there we
stayed for like 30 minutes and
immediately like we were like can we
leave just 30 minutes yeah because it
was literally there was nothing to do
there there was literally nothing to do
there and uh the only reason we stayed
was because mailing was like an hour
late so we're like oh I guess we gotta
wait for May Lin uh but there was like
one Saving Grace to this Festival which
is uh it wasn't there well there was
nothing happening at the beginning but
there was a stage where you know where
music was being played and everything
like that other dance around it yeah
well they dance around it is is there a
name for that can you explain what the
tradition is like uh yeah so they're
basically at the bigger festivals what
they do is uh they build this giant
really really high stage usually it's
like I don't know five ten meters up in
the air yeah
um and then they do this dance usually
at the end of the festival where they
light a fire
um and then there are stage performers
up on stage and then basically everyone
around them they're just dancing like in
a clockwise like kind of circle dance
things
yeah yeah it's probably one of the most
like common types of festivals like
there's some [ __ ] wacky festivals out
there but I'd say that's probably the
most common one yeah so there was
something there was there was one at
this Festival that we went to and there
was nothing happening really on stage
when we first arrived yeah but when
Malin arrived that's when they started
you know the whole dance kind of thing
the whole music that all the traditional
dance and traditional music and
initially I was just like what the [ __ ]
is this I've already had like an awful
time here I just want to leave go
somewhere air conditioned cool off yeah
[ __ ] get this sweat off as a mailing
is like no no go check out the dolls
come on I just got here I was like fine
mailing come on let's go let's go check
out the dance then okay whatever and
so so there's so
so there's this guys they're playing
this traditional song and they're doing
this traditional dance up on stage this
is the one that's like like that one
yeah yeah yeah like like like that one
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh and I mean
they had like everyone up on stage had
like traditional yukatas on except
there's one Grandma who they you know
they have fans of course in the Summer
Festival
um it was really weird just seeing one
traditional grandma in a traditional
Yukata and then she was sporting a Cars
2 fan
you know what nothing says Summer
Festival quite like Lightning McQueen I
was like it's the biggest that's Japan
man tradition mixed with uh you know
Captain and the Disney Corporation it
just likes seeing this traditional dance
just seeing like Lightning McQueen just
up there if it was minions
it would have been very unbranded for us
minions but uh yeah initially no one no
one wanted to like join in and undone
because it was like it's hot it's summer
everyone's sweating but then we had this
for like one we called him like the
alpha right there's there's there was
this one alpha yeah who just got got
down off the stage and like rallied the
crowd together right and he was like he
just did the dance such confidence that
you see one person joining him then two
people then like somehow he just
conjures up an entire [ __ ] line yeah
of people just like dancing around the
stage what a child yeah one absolute
chat yeah and then I remember for one
song he had to like go to the toilet or
something and like without the alpha
everyone was lost we were like what like
I remember because we were weird so you
were a sheep as well yeah we were sheep
yeah
you're literally just like a [ __ ]
flock of sheep after the Sheepdog has
gone away like where do we go what do we
do yeah because it was uh it was it was
me Sydney didis mail in just like
following this guy following his dance
he leaves for a second we're like
what do we do we we are lost the music
hasn't stopped uh uh uh just uh fortnite
dance
and so we do this for like half an hour
45 minutes yeah and we think all right
kind of had enough music stops and the
next ACT is coming on
um and so we're getting ready to leave
and they announced the next ACT
uh and let's just say this was not the
Japanese summer Festival experience I
was expecting because the next ACT they
bring on
they announced them and are like please
in uh introducing bubbly and I'm like
bubbly that does not sound like a
traditional Japanese like music act what
is this [ __ ] Idol group comes on
it's kind of like an idol group comes on
and they say hello we are bubbly let's
[ __ ] get it boys let's go let's go
and they start doing a dance and somehow
in this Summer Festival it turns to an
Idol concert right
people have the little things we should
have right yeah because that's that's
people you people were using their
[ __ ] fans instead of like because I
was saying we they're Lightning McQueen
fans well you know they do that they
wanted the visual K video they also used
fans yeah yeah because I don't know yeah
so if you've been to another concert
normally people have like the glowy
sticks where they do like the glory
dance so they had that kind of dance
they were trying they were trying to get
people to like join along with but they
everyone just kind of used their [ __ ]
fans to like join along and it was like
the most okay here's how you could tell
who the Brits in the crowd were okay so
there was like so everyone was like kind
of like going along with this dance
going along with this Idol concert
um and then I I was like this is this is
this is a bit too much for me this is
very this is this this is not getting
paid for yeah this ain't it for me and
so I like step back and I look to my
left and who would I see I see
um
I see that only two other Brits in Geeks
plus just standing alongside me
we had all thoughts subconsciously
thought the same thing and we all had
all taken a step back and just was like
no no
[Laughter]
that's so funny in the vibe and you're
like no yeah yeah no there's a time and
place for that kind of stuff and just
that day was not the day meanwhile
meanwhile died it's right at the front
of the Hugo yeah let's go bubbly bubbly
let's go
it was like the most surreal experience
I had ever seen because
um because you could tell like there
there was like some fans in the crowd
that were like hardcore fans you know
they knew every dance they knew all of
the lyrics and they were like spread out
in the crowd like they were like like
they were purposely there to like
indoctrinate people right because
because it was like a proper Idol
concert and then I turned to May Lin and
I was like this is my first Japanese
Festival this is my is this is this
traditional and she just tells me and
goes no
I I don't know what's going on and
remind me again this is all happening on
a [ __ ] basketball court this is
happening on a bus okay could you to
give me allow me to paint a better
picture of this how many people were at
this thing would you yeah how big was
this basketball because basketball
courts can't hold more like 100 people
yeah
I said three basketball courts yeah so I
thought that's still tiny so you know
when you're in school there was a
playground I had like a basketball court
and maybe something else oh no actually
like a soccer field yeah the stage was
actually on the tennis court I think so
how how many people were at the Summer
Festival I'd say 300. [ __ ] fair amount
for yeah for that size no no it was a
tiny space and it was absolutely packed
to the brim full of nothing
full of nothing shaved ice balloons and
an Idol concert and yeah it was great I
went to a Summerfest full got a free
Idol concerts no I don't think I don't
think you should say you went to a
Summer Festival because from the sounds
of it you didn't go to a Subway you went
to an uh a Summer Festival themed Idol
concert yeah yeah no no guys I went to
it like I you know you know how I got on
my mind my money's worth out of that
Summer Festival I took one picture I
posted it on Twitter got a hundred a
hundred thousand likes I was like guys I
went to
if people believe I went to a Summer
Festival that's what's important when I
saw that picture I was like I was
imagining you know I saw a lot of people
behind them I was just like oh wow this
must be like a really massive summer
vessel if I really I'd seen outside of
the frame and seeing that it doesn't
extend that much perfectly framed it so
we were like you know frame out the
train frame and like frame out the
basketball court just make it look like
it's a it's a good Summer Festival how
much did it cost you to rent your UK
oh [ __ ] I don't remember it was like I
mean so a lot of places can be 80. yeah
a lot of places can be a bit expensive
she paid 60 or 80 bucks to get sweaty
yeah for like what two hours three hours
yeah two three hours yeah
we just want to karaoke afterwards and
uh uh and uh that was that was the
highlight because it was like yeah you
counter huh in your you guys yeah yeah
oh my God that sounds like a lot of work
it's basically just PJs except it's
socially acceptable I I'm like Giga
white so it it looks weird I'm not sure
when you wear it it just looks like lost
Samurai cosplay I do I do look like
every Facebook photo actually it was so
funny right because when we when we rock
up we had this whole Geeks plus crew
that rocked up to the Summer Festival
yeah like I said we all dressed up for
it we rock up to the Summer Festival
look around and I'm like guess who the
foreigners were they were the ones
wearing the yukatas so it was everyone
else is dressed normally yeah everyone
else was dressed normally so there was
there was like the Japanese people all
dressing in just like normal clothes
it's like just like normal clothes then
there was the foreigners there was a
group of us just rocking up in our UK
and we were just like [ __ ] guys we were
the only ones who actually dressed up
for this I guarantee all the Japanese
people there were like how do we tell
them that it's just accidentally turned
up in a tux to an elementary graduate
like that's what can't do it was that
one time where you you get like the
Halloween party invite and you're like I
should dress up for this yeah you were
the only one who dressed up to this
Halloween party that's the experience we
had oh my god well no yeah it was uh I I
almost hearing that story I almost want
to take you guys to like an actual
problem no I want to go to a problem
yeah yeah let's go somewhere like in the
middle of nowhere